I do have a couple of rules which is
that if it isn't updated at least twice
a day it's not a blog it's a website so
don't fool yourself that you're blogging
when really you're just putting stuff up
online and twice a day is sort of i
think the minimum i think a blog to live
really has to be probably four or five
times a day we post 250 times a week
which is insane and and but but what
I've learned is that the readers the
readers treat it like crack I mean they
will they will they will get they will
take as much as you could possibly give
them and return infinitely more and the
interaction this is second thing I'd say
take your readers as part of your
community this is a dialogue not a
monologue with any luck the dialogue
then becomes a conversation no single
person knows very much and what he knows
he soon forgets so the collective mount
the collective consciousness or
collective mind of the world out there
is what is really what we're trying to
and in our in our case we are trying to
gather the truth we really are we're
trying to understand what the hell is
happening and that means that I will
have a particular line of inquiry outs
of an angle of entry into that because
i'm going to have certain prejudices and
thoughts and feelings and judgments and
and mindset but the goal is to provoke
other stuff too so that we get try and
get to the core of it we try and
actually get to what's actually
happening and I think that's another
thing but look II you can blog about
your garden and it's a brilliant blog I
also think the other critical thing so
more than one time today love them more
than once a day enter a dialogue thirdly
I really think you have to be yourself I
think this is a medium about personality
and voice
it's about honesty and openness and
people can smell in or theater citty a
mile away and you know that's really
what facebook is I mean at some point
now with social media everybody has a
blog i mean what i was doing 10 years
ago is now ubiquitous at the time when
we first started no one in the main know
none of my peers in journalism could
understand why on earth I would stop
writing essays the new york times
magazine or or or or being a to do this
and my feeling was why not I get to
write I having been an editor of an
online of an opinion magazine having
having been a columnist having done
having written books I'm knowing through
that process every time you had to go
through some authority figure um you
know editor proprietor colleagues blah
blah blah publisher god help us
publicists all that ghastliness um
suddenly who are you go right to the
reader forget everything the only
question is whether I could ever make a
living at it and for six years didn't I
mean you know but I did it for the hell
of it and I think sometimes the this
generation that grew up with this is not
don't don't remember them understand how
hard it was with great writers in the
past so get their stuff out there the
agents and the publishers and the
manuscripts in the desperate attempt to
get your reviews published and then they
will watch it and cut it in half or
rewrite it or or or wouldn't publish it
for political reasons or I mean you have
no idea what people went through and now
we're fine
you